Let's talk about stay at home moms or stay at home wives.
Being a stay at home mom is absolutely
the most difficult thing I've ever done.
I don't think we should be undermining it
by saying that it's easier than working a 9 to 5
or that your life is gonna be magically easier
because you quit your job
and you did the honorable thing of staying home with your kids
if you could financially.
Everybody on social media wants to paint this picture
that it's just so easy and amazing and fulfilling
staying home all the time.
The problem with that is it's not true.
And here's why. And no,
men are not to blame for this.
We were meant to be in a village.
The reason there's so many reels of women having freakouts
and waiting for their husband to come home from work
is because we were never meant to be alone and isolated
raising children. People back then lived in villages.
They lived on family compounds.
You had your abuela or your grandma,
you had your aunts, you had your sisters.
Fertile women would free bleed in a tent
while the post menopausal women would take care of them
and watch the kids. When a new mom had a baby,
she was really meant just to nurse that baby
and make sure it had the best foundation at its earliest years.
While sister, mom,
aunt, cousins
and other people in the Village
Slash family would Help raise all the other kids,
they would help clean, they would help cook.
And now stay at home moms are frowned upon if they even hire a maid.
You hear comments like, oh, whatever,
it's because she has a maid.
A maid is probably the smallest thing
that could help a stay at home mom.
When I worked in corporate life and I had my taxes,
I hired a CPA. If you needed marketing done,
you hired a social media expert.
If you needed administrative assistance,
you hired a secretary.
But people are going to rag on a stay at home mom that has a maid.
You already know I am like an anti feminist. Okay?
On the other side, we don't need men and women looking at these reels
and videos of these moms saying,
I am lonely, I am isolated,
or I can't wait for my husband to come home
or he needs to help.
They shouldn't be looking down on them because the truth is,
there is so much overwhelming work to do in the home.
Now, do I think it is a man's job to be a side mom
when he comes home from work?
No, I don't.
I think it's a cultural thing.
I think it was never. I think they were meant to work,
they were meant to hunt, they were meant to go to war,
and women would stay here and get help from other women.
I think we should be having Our moms coming over,
our aunts, our cousins,
our nieces, and everybody should have a hand in raising the children
while dad is at work. And we cannot blame men for this.
Women all the time are like, oh,
he gets to escape to an 8 to 5 job,
and then he comes home and he wants to rest.
And I'm still working a 24 hour job.
You are, and I completely agree with that.
It's freaking hard. But this is a cultural issue.
This is why I've always liked the Latin cultures and the Hispanics,
because they kept their family units together.
I live on the southern border
and this is the truth
of a little 19 Mexican year old girl gets pregnant,
guess what? It doesn't matter because she will stay home.
Her abuela, her tias,
her cuz, her primos,
they will all freaking help her raise those babies or that baby.
And they keep their family unit as a village.
And I have a ton of friends who are Hispanic
who had their children a very young,
in their 20s, and it wasn't frowned upon,
nobody freaked out, nobody talked about getting rid of them.
They're not as isolated. It can be done.
And there's not this fear factor around having babies,
especially young, which that's a whole
another cultural aspect about our white American culture
of having babies and how we get so scared if we get pregnant young,
which you already know. I'm an advocate
Advocate for having babies younger. Okay,
that's my rant. I'm just.
I'm so tired of, like,
even on the side of the fence that most people are on with me,
they see these reels, and they have these comments of these women, like,
leaving their children with their husband the minute 5:00 happens.
Yes, it's because she is taking on the job of 20 different people.
But again, it is a cultural thing.
It is not to. We are not to place that blame on men.
It is our culture. And now I'm starting to see people change it.
But I'm so glad people are starting to realize this.
And now it's going viral on Instagram with, like, homesteaders.
People are building family compound.
You don't have to be in the same house,
but they're building a village,
having a farm. There's four houses on the property. That those are